[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're discussing hogwarts
professor minerva mcgonagall
minerva mcgonagall is a scottish
half-blood witch that attended hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry we
know a lot about her past her love
interests her career path her parents
thanks to extra publications from
rowling but one important aspect about
her character remains unclear her age
you see her age is subject to a
considerable amount of speculation and
this is because in fantastic beasts 2
the crimes of grindelwald we see a young
woman by the name of mcgonagall at
hogwarts a woman who if i had to guess
is in her 20s or so
we know that mcgonagall teaches
alongside dumbledore and we know that at
one point she's a young professor at the
school so what's the problem well all of
this would be fine if it had been
consistent with what jk rowling had
revealed about mcgonagall in the
original series originally rowling
stated that mcgonagall started teaching
at the school in 1956 at the age of 21.
however fantastic beast 2 takes place in
the year 1927
29 years before she's supposed to have
taught there which just doesn't really
add up expanding on this if she really
had started at the school in 1956 at the
age of 21 then it means that she was
born in the year 1935.
this adds to the confusion even more as
that seven or eight years after she's
seen on screen
harry potter cannon also supports
rowling's claim that mcgonagall began
teaching there in 1956.
in a 1995 conversation between umbridge
and mcgonagall mcgonagall reveals that
she had been working at hogwarts 39
years this december which is consistent
with what rowling had said initially in
the most recent trailer for fantastic
beasts 3 the secrets of dumbledore we
see young mcgonagall once again warning
dumbledore about something pertaining to
the imminent threat that is gelet
grindelwald so what on earth is going on
well the first thing i want to address
is that mcgonagall we've seen so far has
not yet been referred to by her first
name the mcgonagall from the harry
potter series is minerva and at this
point this new mcgonagall has no link to
that name
at least not from within the film this
has led some fans to the conclusion that
this mcgonagall must be minerva's mother
but i've got a big wrench to throw in
that theory you see the published
screenplay for the film contradicts this
entire argument as it's clearly shown
that this is in fact minerva and no
maneuver wasn't named after her mother
her mother was isabelle ross
on top of all of that minerva's father
who she got the mcgonagall name from was
a muggle which means there's no large
wizarding family that shares the
mcgonicle name
this eliminates other prospects like
distant relatives cousins etc
so what does all of this mean how can
mcgonagall be teaching at hogwarts
school before she's even born i'd like
to imagine that there is some convoluted
explanation for breach of canon perhaps
involving a time turner or alternate
dimensions but i think the harsh reality
here is that this is no carefully chosen
plot twist but instead is an attempt to
shoehorn a popular character like
mcgonagall back into the story am i
happy that canon is broken certainly not
but i must admit i'd be lying if i said
that i wasn't happy to see a fan
favorite like mcgonagall slotted back
into the story
if you guys want to know the full
backstory of minerva mcgonagall from her
birth to her life after the battle of
hogwarts then check out my video in the
pinned comment what do you guys think
how is mcgonagall's presence in
fantastic beasts explained leave a
comment down below
until next time remember
differences of habit and language are
nothing at all if our aims are identical
and our hearts are open
you